[Music]
what brings in today
I have a hard time focusing you get
enough sleep every night
[Music]
how much is enough six to eight hours
Oh way more than that I had a friend she
was prescribed done at her role and now
she's very alert you know some people
abused that or all right let's get you
healthy I want you to try losing 55
pounds that's the weight of a Siberian
Husky you want me to pull a medium-sized
working dog off of my body it's trying
to feel like everyone's lives are going
places and the mind sort of stuck
hold it hold it please try not to leave
all your stuff in the hallway help me
the third time this month change is
possible if I keep interviewing no one
thinks I'm the right fit I would love
you to walk me through CPR or this doll
oh I'm sorry this child was dead I need
to get a teeny bit healthier we have
raised as well as $129 you do know that
people can run outside that is zero and
lock
I ran today you do that somebody chasing
you over did you do doing it sorry I'm
talking myself my sister she owns a
company house in pet city right I'll
stay bad taste in music you're the new
girl I'm the nighttime guy Jaron
I'm done with the drinking I'm don't
like the smoke 50,000 people from around
the world are racing today I want to run
the New York City Marathon I think that
is such a good idea thank you so much
I'm really good at making profiles God
woman it's not that bad I'm just gonna
give you mine okay do you know how to
spell herpes
[Music]
my whole life the world told me I was
lazy because the way I looked was trying
to turn my life around everything's
gonna be fine people help doors for me
how old doors for you this is my you
change your life was never about your
weight was about you taking
responsibility for yourself we're going
back
[Music]